- But first, Santa comes
down the chimney in 11 days
to deliver toys everywhere, people.
So this week we've asked all of you
to nominate some real-life Santas
who make our world a better place
'cause we need these stories,
we love these stories.
All you had to do was pull
out your Pilot G-2 Gel ink pen
the go-to pen of the
"Kelly Clarkson Show,"
and write us a letter
about a real life St. Nic.
So today's letter comes
from Kelli, great name.
(audience laughing)
She's a reporter from also great place,
my home state of Texas.
We have Kelli in our audience.
So can you read us what
you wrote, Kelli, hi.
- Yes, hi Kelly.
I spell it with an I not a with Y.
But it's okay, it's still the same name.
- It's okay, we're still
hanging, we're cool.
- Okay, I wrote dear Kelly,
I'd like to nominate Willa
Johnson as a real-life Santa.
Every week she drives 100 miles
from her home in Fort
Worth to Athens, Texas
to deliver home cooked meals,
she makes herself for
kids in low-income areas.
When Willa was a kid,
her mom dropped her off
at a community center.
One day they served moldy sandwiches.
Willa promised, when she grew up,
she would never let a kid eat
something that's not fresh.
It has to be something full
of sugar, butter, and love.
(audience laughing)
Now, even after Willa was
diagnosed with cancer,
she continues to provide hot meals
for those kids even while
going through chemo.
- Oh my gosh, so selfless.
(audience applauding)
Well, we have Willa on the line y'all,
but she thinks that it's just to tell us
about her efforts to help
kids, which is beautiful,
and we would have her here
in the first place for that,
but she has no idea, she's
today's real-life Santa.
(upbeat music)
♪ Real-life Santa ♪
(audience applauding)
All right, let's bring Willa up,
but don't spoil the
surprise, she doesn't know.
Okay, Grinch?
Okay.
(audience laughing)
Hi Willa, I'm Kelly
Clarkson, nice to meet you!
(audience applauding)
- I'm so glad to see you.
- I am so honored to meet you,
I've heard so many wonderful things
about you and your heart,
and you are just so selfless.
So we're so inspired by
what you do for kids.
How did this all start?
- I used to work for the state of Texas
and I landed in Athens.
And once I wanted to just
do hot meals for the kids,
because I know what it
felt like to grow up,
to struggle and be served nasty food
at different centers and stuff like that.
And I said, "When I grow up,
I'm gonna serve kids hot food
"if I ever got the opportunity."
And that's what I have been doing,
serving kids hot meals, home cooked meals.
I'm not known as Willa in Athens,
I'm known as the food lady.
And I am so glad
(audience laughing)
to be a part of that community.
Since the pandemic has hit,
it has really hurt my funding so bad
because when school was let out
and the kids couldn't go to school,
of course, the people started calling
"Ms. Willa, how can you help us
feed our children and stuff?"
So I said, "Okay."
So that's what happened to our funding.
But every year I try to do something big
for my kids in Athens, Texas,
for us during the Christmas holiday time.
One year I did a bicycle parade,
this year--
- Oh my gosh!
- I wanna do a whole nother
different kind parade
just giving out toys and hot meals.
- Oh my God, and a little
bit goes a long way, right?
When it comes to helping, right?
- But I like to do big
things 'cause I'm from Texas.
(audience laughing)
we do big things, baby.
(audience applauding)
- I didn't mean what you were doing,
I meant everybody helping
out in their little ways,
actually goes along way.
I know you go big, I
saw the belt, the shirt.
We are the same, we come
from the same place.
So I love it, I go
bigger, go home as well.
But we happen to have someone here
who says that you're the real-live Santa.
So I think you know this other Kelli.
Do you know this Kelli right here?
(audience applauding)
- Hi Ms. Willa!
- You wanted to say something, right?
- [Kelli] Yes, and we're
both gonna cry, Willa.
- Oh God, now I'm going to, oh no.
- I know, we need tissues.
- My makeup artist is
gonna hate me, oh God.
- Willa, I have done lots of stories
through my journalism career,
but you've touched my heart.
You truly help kids, and
you are our real-life Santa.
I love you, you have a heart of gold.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh, you two.
Well, Willa, you are a real-life Santa.
And we mean in a big way, not a small way,
remember, I said that.
And that's just not in
the name as well though,
Pilot G-2 Gel ink pen is
designed for overachievers,
just like you ma'am, with big hearts.
And that's why Pilot's using their pen
to write you a check for
$5,000, will that help?
(audience applauding)
- Yes, it'll help, thank you.
- Oh my gosh, and I just wanted to add,
since you're from my home state
and I was also one of those kids
that grew up on that
kind of food, nasty food,
and I was like, "I will help when I can."
I'm gonna double it, and I'm
gonna give you five more.
- Oh my God.
So that's 10 grand total!
Thank you so much, Willa.
(audience applauding)
We love you, we appreciate
you, we're lifting you up,
and we're thinking about you.